Pakistan supreme court has ordered the
release of the former prime minister
Imran Khan describing his arrest as
illegal Khan had been detained earlier
in the week sparking days of protests by
his supporters he faces multiple charges
including corruption for an update Osama
bin Javed is joining us from Islamabad
so what happens and what's likely to
happen next then
well he's going to stay in the custody
of the Islamabad police and the national
accountability Bureau for his own
safekeeping he's been transferred to the
same guest house that he was being kept
at at police lines and the court has
ordered him to appear before the
Islamabad high court tomorrow morning to
get the case continued from where it was
disrupted according to the Supreme Court
of Pakistan Imran Khan's arrest was not
lawful because no citizen should be
arrested from the premises of the court
and it has deemed it illegal that does
not mean that Imran Khan's legal issues
are over the national accountability
Bureau continues to say that he needs to
be remanded in their custody because
he's not been cooperating with them he's
also been indicted in another case where
his party leaders have been arrested and
hundreds of protesters belonging to the
Pakistan service also have also been
arrested after the the protests turned
violent in the last few hours we we saw
crowds swelling up here behind us at the
D chalk the road reading towards the
Pakistani Parliament and police once
again firing uh large volleys of tear
gas at them trying to disperse them
arresting people and their sporadic fire
that we can still hear behind us as
these protesters try to come together
the police goes after them and Picks
Them Up and puts them away so it is
going to be an interesting another
interesting round of politicking and
legal issues that Imran Khan faces as
the military is being called in in
multiple provinces to take care of the
Law and Order and Imran Khan's party
alleging that all of these is being
orchestrated by a government because it
is afraid of going into elections and
we've heard from government leaders
saying that this is to do with Imran
Khan facing the courts as other leaders
have faced them in the past and they
allege that he was corrupt during his
time in power
thank you so much Osama bin Javed
reporting from Islamabad